The snake in the garden of Eden is a
really interesting character.
Human beings and their closest
biological relative chimpanzees are
innately afraid of and attracted to
reptiles.
They automatically trigger off responses
in a part of the brain called the
Amygdala that's associated with anxiety
and I think the evolutionary reason for
this is that mammals and reptiles have
been at war in a sense over ecological
turf for something between $60,
million and 200 million years.
Reptilian features which are cold
blooded,
a piercing I'd tooth lurking,
nocturnal out there,
out in the unknown.
Outward chaos is the snake is
representative of the unknown in a
sense,
and it's an ambivalent feature and you
see that you see that even in its used
in mythology because for example,
the dragon in in,
in western culture is a negative
feature,
but in Chinese culture it's positive
feature.
So the unknown is like that.
It's positive and negative.
The snake in the garden of Eden is
representative of all those things that
lurk.
When you think you know what you're
doing and when you think you know what
you're doing,
you've carved out this little.
Eden has little paradise in which you're
operating,
but there's always something that's
lurking and that's all the things you're
not paying attention to.
Well,
that's the snake and we're not snake
pops up.
People are.
We're wired.
If a little snake pops out,
we might want to run away from it,
but like we're curious about that.
We're going to go over there and
investigate right away.
Now,
when chimps come across a python in the
forest,
they have a specific cry.
It's called a snake wrath,
and the chimps who don't like snakes,
they don't run from it.
They back off and then they watched the
thing.
They cannot tear their eyes away from it
and some of the most stand there and
look at it for 10 minutes.
Other individuals will stand there for
hours watching the snake.
The unknown is fascinating.
We can't look away from it.
We have to encounter it even if it's
terrifying.
It's partly why,
you know,
teenagers like horror movies,
they're driven to look at the snake.
They're are driven to interact with the
snake.
In Genesis,
of course,
interacting with the snake means the end
of paradise.
Just like it does in life,
there are ideas that the serpent in the
garden of Eden was Satan and trying to
destroy God's handiwork.
People often look back in their lives
and they say,
well,
you know,
I got knocked out of my little paradise
by,
you know,
this particular event,
but looking back on it really made me
grow up.
It really made me mature.
Whatever it is,
that's the serpent in the garden of Eden
certainly plays that role.
It's a catalyst.
Much of what's unknown is redemptive.
Much of what's unknown gives life saver.
It,
it,
it provides the kind of excitement that
justifies suffering.
The injunction behind religious thought
fundamentally is that you should live
your life in such a way that the
suffering it has to contain because
you're confined and vulnerable is
justified.